I said I'm a leak ingredients a piece
how are you my friend
Salam how are you how you been good to
see ya good to see you too I've been
eating some vegetables lately oh we were
just talking about that yeah good thank
you you too also number one genocide the
only genocide that's happening here in
the world we don't hear much about it
why is that I don't know but Rehan Jia
people are indigenous people living in
their ancestral land in Burma and they
are just being killed slaughtered thrown
out of their homes 284 villages have
been burned to ashes in 15 days how many
284 in 15 days but now it is more than
400 for the average Western or people
who are they probably never heard Burma
can you give us a little bit of a
picture where where is this at is by
China but mine Miyama
in Southeast Asia yes North with that is
China and west of that is Bangladesh and
only East is Thailand huh and how long
is this genocide been happening well it
has been a slow-burning genocide for
years but now they are going for the
final solution and you know majority of
Rania's are no longer in that land they
have been thrown out huh now you
actually you just came back from there
recently our society sent Li came back
this was my second trip to the area and
it's not that easy to get in there I
heard well you know getting inside Burma
it's almost impossible now to that area
not just hard it's impossible
I made it inside right no I did not make
it inside of Burma I cannot go there
they will just throw me in the jail
unless they get hold of me how close did
you make it I went to the border from
the Bangladesh side that's where the
refugees are there are almost a million
refugees at this moment there are very
religious people very
practicing people you rarely find any
woman who doesn't have her head covered
they're very religious people and they
were very self-reliant people they were
living off their land they were not
dependent on anybody the government took
away their citizenship is 1982 and
because of that they cannot enter a
school they cannot go to a clinic they
cannot have a job so they were living
off land their own land and they're not
dependent on anybody suddenly there are
million people who are dependent on the
world to give them food there is still
want to work but work is not allowed
they're just sitting in these camps and
next to each other badly from one and
and these are not proper tents as you
see in Syrian crisis and all that they
just cut the hill wood from the hill and
put the stick up there and put some
plastic at the top of it or some sheet
that's that's where how they're living
and they put you know roots of that tree
to dry up so they can cook with it so
they are very self-reliant people so I
saw lot of their hearts have not locked
I mean more than Chicago every hundred
of home or so home I'm saying hot
superboots Bob wood plastic arts I will
see a little bit of small you know solar
panel I said wow these guys are weird
monster Chicago so it turns out the
government will have electricity for the
Buddhist Burmese but in the same village
they will not let have electricity
Muslims have so Muslim went into solar
panel business so that's how they have
been surviving so while running away
some of them were able to pick up their
little it's very small solar panel one
foot by one foot and they brought with
them tell us about some of the people
you met you met some the only surviving
Imams yesterday say you know what I was
meeting people I keep meeting people who
have horrible story to tell from a
village called Tula Tula tul i-20 or a
lie
so I said what is happening to laterally
I said what so people are saying half of
the old people were murdered and a lot
of women were raped including young
girls so I said did you had any leaders
so yeah former chair of our village
council is here I said take me to him so
I spoke to him then I met another former
chair of Tillett Olli and I'd learned
that you know as villages were being
burned all around they were assured by
the current chair who is a Buddhist
Burmese that okay don't worry nothing
will happen to you verse converse they
will burn your houses but you'll be okay
so people who are running around all
around but these people stay trusting
that Mayor and guess what 8:00 a.m. on
August 30th helicopters landed and they
came attacking and killing they kill the
separated men and women killed men and
boys and women they asked him to set
8:00 a.m. until 3:00 4:00 p.m. in water
just had up and then they came out they
will take five girls and five soldiers
they will take them to temple and rape
them and so while talking here there I
said did he had any mom she's all yes we
had any mom so I met the Imam so it
turned out there were five must it and
five Imams and four of them were
murdered he's the only one who survived
the way he survived was that they were
some of them were doing a meeting at a
watchtower to watch out what's going on
and that's what the attack begin so they
were able to find out and ran and since
military came from the north they were
in the south they were able to save
their families as well now we know that
after World War two one of the greatest
degraded genocide to happen you were
actually a part of helping bring
creating awareness to that you did a lot
of great work for the situation in
Bosnia I was a you know just a horrific
you know ethnic cleansing that was
happening there and now it seems like we
have another great genocide of having
again and the world is what what's the
world doing
situation is worse than Bosnia in some
ways you know in Bosnia more people
probably were killed but one common
thing is rape in Bosnia I remember fifty
thousand Muslim Bosnian roomin were
raped yes and I remember sitting in the
I have daughters God has blessed me with
her daughters I was sitting in room in
their room as they were little girls at
that time a little crying thinking of
those sisters in Bosnia so I launched a
campaign actually in America got all
Muslim organizations together and then
we align ourselves with national
organization of women and we have
marches and Moss station in hundred
cities and we got raped declare a war
crime and many people have been punished
since in Burma's situation that's their
main weapon the user is an actual weapon
actually as a weapon and that's how they
do it I mean it's not just some soldier
got crazy and he did anything like that
it's nothing like that it's a very bland
method and that's how they do it United
Nations surveyed and they say 52 percent
of all women this survey during GA women
have been raped how they do it they will
go for example in one case they will
just pick up girls and take it to mosque
and they raped them the mosque while
soldiers are having guns towards all the
villagers
so villagers hear all of that right they
were their babies in there girls crying
as young as six year old brother
I met 13 year old I met 14 year old who
got everybody in the family killed and
she got raped so when they hear this
they say Oh run from here because Muslim
honor their women and everybody does but
Muslim have extraordinary importance
given to that to all sexual violence so
so people ran because of that other
places they will go in the village just
pick up a girl and rape and once this
happened for a few months you say oh
what in the world is going on
I met a girl in in Indonesia through the
boat she arrived and I say you know why
did he leave you see my parents sold
everything and put me on board and he
said alone by yourself and she will not
answer me she'll just look down so a
person next to her say you know the
reason is that these soldiers will come
every week air and there and just barge
into the home and draper so parents
wanted her to at least be free from that
slavery
so they're using rape as a weapon to of
genocide so people can run away from
their homes
and who exactly is doing this military
the military mainly what do you call in
the Burmese military yeah you can call
it Burmese military they have another
name for it but you are miss military is
a good way of saying it and you have to
them there's a religion connected to it
we obviously we don't blame a religion
like people try to blame Islam but they
are connected there's some extremist
model the difference is that there's no
one extremist monk there are a whole lot
of extremists who are Buddha Buddhist
they are Buddhists yes and one extremist
model for example they are giving
theological justification they're saying
that oh you know they got this
philosophy of people are born again and
things like that so they say Muslims
actually are not human beings they were
insects so when you're killing them
you're not killing human being you're
killing insects this is gone theology
now that is considered extremist monk
but now the most respected highly
regarded Buddhist monk who is currently
visiting America by the way he lecturing
the military officers American militia
no no the Buddhist officers in Burma in
Burma they are all sitting on the floor
he's sitting on the stage all by himself
yeah he is telling them killing non
killing non-buddhists is not a crime
it's okay yeah and he's giving
theological justification Islam that's a
crime it's close limb commit crimes but
but but you would here imagine if the if
the situation was reversed now right
you see these double standards happening
why do you have so you mentioned now
these commanders these in the military
this is something that they're they're
propagating and they're using their
religion Buddhism to go ahead and and
not some freak groups like Isis type
which is a isolated group but they're
the whole military main stream people
mainstream not in regional monks are
telling the main army that says okay to
kill Wow there's a around record this is
on video by the way you can google it
and the guy is visiting America he was
insane
Los Angeles a week ago went to Minnesota
now he's in Austin coming to America on
a full visa to preach Buddhism to the
Buddhists here while he is on record
just two months ago preaching that is so
critical non-buddhist he got the visa he
got a visa and everything probably
nobody knows that how horrible this
person is I think that's why some of us
are writing to State Department what's
his name
sit go sit WAP so something like that
what's the other main mom that they had
him on the terrazzo Russell yeah he is
the number one preacher of hate I think
military controls him
one of his I met one of his friend who's
a Muslim that preacher and that Muslim
guy he's a refugee and he became refugee
because that hate monger told him it's
not a good time for you to be here you
better get out of the country he says
that he doesn't used to be that bad but
military took control of his monastery
and Buddhist monastery women aren't
allowed not allowed to stay inside the
monastery you know at night and there'll
be no woman in the monastery except in
his monastery there is a woman and that
woman gives him injections and whatnot
so he thinks that military somehow is
controlling this Hmong to continue to do
the dirty propaganda but that guy people
knew his ex
promised we're talking snuggle which is
the number when marks of that country
who is saying based on the Buddhist
theology of whatever interpretation he
came up with it's okay to kill
non-buddhists it's okay to pretty much
kill anyone who's not a part of Buddhism
yep Muslims in particularly now in the
city of course is addressing the
military a military officer does ring
infrared of him yeah he's justifying
them in case they have some guilty
conscious of killing Muslim is
justifying them it's okay to kill no is
the Buddhist world is the Buddhist world
speaking out well there are some people
is speaking of the Lama have spoken out
American with his community meaning
people who are convert to Buddhism in
America they have been good allies of
Burma task force I am chair of Burma
task force USA and we have been working
on this to stop the genocide for five
years so they they are good allies they
have been speaking out against them and
I recently I was speaking at Roosevelt
University on this topic a Buddhist
stood up and he started sharing the
teachings of Buddha that this is wrong
and it reminded me how Muslim trying to
use Quran to tell what Isis is doing
wrong so they are unfortunately on
defensive although it's none of their
fault but in Burma right now all
laypeople political government and
military all on the same page they don't
believe anything wrong is going on over
there well the rest of the world is
crying what is going on
but rest of the world unfortunately not
is stopping this genocide
some lunatic he lets off a pipe bomb and
he's somehow connected to even though
he's going to do an opposite to Islam
it's all over mainstream media and you
know it's a big frenzy and then we've
like you talked about before Muslims
it's one of the almost like if there's
six pillar it would be you know we
become professional condemned right yeah
so now what are you seeing your on the
ground what are you seeing as far as the
media like we hear a little bit here and
there but where is the the world
globally are they hearing about the
national problem with America is that
whatever happens in America we think
that's the main story whatever happens
in the
is a very secondary if not below that so
media is covering here and there what is
happening in terms of genocide but it's
not going on that case because who are
these people far away people Muslim to
begin with so you demonize Muslim so
much that anybody killing Muslims is
okay type of a business of course the
Trump administration which regularly
speaks he himself against Muslims and
Muslim community and now he says that
Islamist and Chinese are the made the
most important threat to America I mean
China got guns who are Muslims they
they're buying guns from America don't
sell them period so there's a fear of
Islam would justifies these type of
things so when I see what what Muslims
in Burma are accused of they are the
same thing they accuse of Muslims in
America the only difference is would
thank God we have law in order and if
somebody attacks us they get arrested in
Burma it's okay to say anything do
anything and you will always get away
what's yeah that's my next question
what's the justification behind that
because you know usually there's some
pictures painted there's something as
propagated and two-pump people up so you
had you mentioned one thing about the
the actual justification basically
they're saying they're trying to take
over Burma well Muslims are not more
than more than the couple of percent but
how they're gonna take over the country
Muslims are no harmie of their own in
Burma there are five groups Christians
and Buddhists who are fighting the
Burmese government with guns how many
groups at least five yeah it used to be
you know in principle there are about
twenty but five are main groups fighting
Burmese government with guns they are
not called terrorists these ranges are
called terrorists who are peacefully
begging please give our citizenship back
to us so for hunger people have an
option follow what other Burmese are
doing fight with the government fight
with the military who is killing them
they are so peaceful they have chosen
okay now we just want our citizenship
back they are not asking for country
they're not asking to do anything else
they say just let us live in our
location you know there are indigenous
people living in their ancestral lands
just let us live so they're people
without a citizenship and without a home
without a land a lot of citizens and
they got taken away she was taken away
actually the last Muslim used to be
members of the Parliament in Burma
brother actually the last member of the
Parliament who retired just in 2015 is
sitting right here and check-in us so
there are people without a citizenship
and without a land now
yeah well of all that land all their
mosque everything is destroyed so where
they are they have them in concentration
camps well there are two places genocide
is going on in Burma so they have taken
them about 200 thousand are in those
concentration camps where hardly any
food is given about 100 to 200 thousand
are running around are in villages which
still have not been attacked but they
keep attacking last two weeks they have
a turtle attacked and destroyed 20
villages so they're just sitting duck at
this moment
and they cannot run to Bangladesh
because the main route to Bangladesh
they have mined them so people go
through they get blasted so the only
route they go further south on this sea
and luckily somebody can pick up
nobody's picking them up I recently saw
photos they have taken bumbles and put
some plastic bottles milk bottles to it
and they they're floating on it for four
miles so many of them are drowning what
about the the prime visit the Prime
Minister there she actually won the
Nobel Peace Prize is that right
well yeah what's she saying doing if
she's not even in prime minister this is
called the some senior counselor and
because by law she is prohibited from
becoming a prime minister because the
military before they allowed
quote/unquote democracy they change the
constitution and in that Constitution
everything is designed for military to
keep control in their hand so military
for example there is a clause in the
Constitution that military can do
anything you cannot try a military in
any court in Burma or outside
so and and they control the military
they control the most of the thing
interior border and things of this
nature so she is essentially a
collaborator she doesn't have much power
but she has a power to resign she is not
resigning so it means she's responsible
for it tell us more you on the ground
there you you weren't able to get in why
won't they let them they don't allow
media in the place they don't allow even
the United Nations inside that area
where genocide has been committed the
United Nations has developed a committee
to investigate they're not giving visa
to that committee to investigate
actually when they started this major
war major killing and genocide which I
consider to be a final solution on
August 25th they have been building up
for a couple of months a month and a
half before they kick out the United
Nation all the non-governmental
organization who are providing help
relief they were all kicked out before
they started this operation so it was
well planned by the military Wow what
also have you seen on the ground there
sure any other experiment a situation is
terrible for people who are living there
and they need a whole lot of help and
this help cannot be given by you know
you and me giving the dollar here and
dollar there it's a it's a magnitude in
which governments need to do more I mean
I had day speaking last Sunday in
Cleveland and Doctors Without Borders
one of their member board of directors
who also she just came back after
serving two months in Bangladesh she's a
midwife and she was saying that she has
been to six or seven conflict zone you
say I have never seen anything like that
ever anywhere so people are in terrible
shape it's a very tiny very narrow type
of an island and there are million
people sitting there couple of millions
were already residents of that area
there is a one tiny road of which goes
through that area
and it is always clogged because the
well-meaning Bangladeshi Muslim bringing
things for them and everybody so what
they need is I think something which I
pleaded for Haiti and it happened they
need ten helicopters 20 transport
helicopters so they take it food from
the airport and they deliver it to
multiple distribution point now people
sit there for almost 2/3 of the day to
get food and Russian and that's not
enough and because of rape there are a
lot of unwanted pregnancies and
different things 80 percent of the
people there are women and children men
were either killed or they're in prison
or somewhere so more distribution more
aid airlift transport helicopters that
will alleviate this situation but the
worst scenario is that China and India
India is emerging as a real enemy of
Muslim I mean China is chemists and all
that but they are supportive of me Imam
but they are not emerging as enemies of
Muslim but India is emerging as enemies
or Muslim these two countries are
forcing Bangladesh to just throw these
people back to me about back to where I
mean genocide is happening right there
there is still coming in to Bangladesh
and you want them to start going back so
when I was there until number 29th or
30th they were distributing forms for
people to fill in and go back go back
where which land which property they're
going to take them to concentration camp
they shouldn't go nobody should be
forced to go unless their citizenship is
restored so their rights are at least
theoretically restored they get their
property they land and their house is
back or get compensation for it and
there is some force either you get a
force out of India people print them in
the in defending themselves so they are
there or send the United Nations or send
a bangladesh army or maybe the
bangladesh
the Miyama our army together safeguard
people because they have done this in 78
91 95 2012 2016 2017 they keep doing
that and then these people go back go
back to start their life from ground
zero
what is ground zero for them no house
nothing no education no job no land to
do what whatever you married is this I
mean this is the first genocide brother
which is well documented through
satellite before and after they have
photos up before after before and after
you can see all this is available online
so there is no genocide in the world
history which is as well-documented as
this one except those people who say
never again are just sitting idle on
their seats so you need to say you know
never again is happening again let's do
something to stop it never again is
happening again never again is happening
people are just let it happen you have
real time real time live under this at
light eyes and those images are printed
everywhere yeah people want to get a
hold of you if they want to try to do
their part
yes but mark task force dot o-r-g varma
task force dot o-r-g or they can go to
burma muslims dot o-r-g
and we two things you can do sign up we
issue action alert that every week you
could do one or ten minute fifteen
minute and there are things which you
can do which are effective and for this
class if you want to donate you can
donate there we're working to stop the
genocide we were doing that for five
years now they're coming to final
solution and this is the time for people
who care for humanity who care for their
daughters who care for Elijah and and
Maria and Maryam and Fatima this is the
time for you to realize you need to
stand up America gives us rights we can
is take a stand we can contact our
Congress persons who
contact our senators the and and there
are bills in Senate and the house which
we are trying to push and people are
listening but the thing is are we are
enough of us are standing up yeah thank
you so much me got Almighty Allah reward
you for your efforts and a wonderful
work you're doing thank you for sharing
your experience man thank you thank you